what's that that sound
that call sounds like something a crow
would make but not quite
that's actually the call of a really
interesting bird called clark's
nutcracker these birds are cousins of
the american crow which you might see
and hear around where you live except
that the clark's nutcrackers like to
live up in the mountains and alpine
ecosystems in the western united states
where the winters are pretty harsh with
lots of snow and there are lots of
evergreen trees like pine trees which
keep their leaves all throughout the
year
but what would this bird possibly eat in
this kind of ecosystem i'll give you a
hint it's in the bird's name
turns out that clark's nutcrackers love
eating seeds and not just any seeds but
mainly the seeds of pine trees like this
one the white bark pine
and it's actually good for the trees
that nutcrackers eat those seeds wait
what
let's take a look at the white bark pine
these trees have cones which hold their
seeds other pine tree species have cones
that will open when the temperature is
warm enough or if the air is especially
dry or
when the cone is exposed to fire
but for the white bark pine their cones
don't open on their own instead the
cones have to be pried open and it's the
clark's nutcracker that does this as it
looks for seeds to eat but the
nutcracker doesn't just eat the seeds it
stores them in what's called a cache or
a safe place where they store the seeds
to eat them later remember these birds
live in an alpine ecosystem where the
spring and summer are pretty warm and
there's lots to eat but the winters are
cold and long with very little to eat
so the nutcrackers have to stock up
in fact the nutcrackers will cash up to
100 000 seeds in a single year i can't
remember where i put my phone half the
time but the nutcrackers don't retrieve
all of these seeds many of the caches
won't be used by the nutcrackers so
those seeds germinate and grow into new
whitebark pines and the cycle continues
nutcrackers rely on whitebark pines as
an important food source and the
whitebark pines rely on nutcrackers to
plant their seeds and on top of that
more than 100 other alpine species of
plants and animals benefit from that
relationship between the clark's
nutcracker and the white bark pine for
example douglas squirrels will also eat
seeds from white bark pine cones and
mountain bluebirds and northern flickers
may nest in the white bark pine too
when you look at it all of these
interactions that occur in this alpine
ecosystem are like a web each population
interacts with many other populations
and each population is affected by
non-living parts of the environment like
temperature and snowfall so a change in
any one part of an ecosystem can lead to
changes in many of the ecosystems
populations for example if something
happens to the nutcrackers and their
population starts to decline that could
cause some big problems for the pines
that need these birds to plant their
seeds in turn if the white bark pine
starts to decline too that can have
negative impacts on all the other
species that rely on this tree like
squirrels bluebirds and flickers
even though it seems like a perfect
relationship between the nutcracker and
the pine in the alpine ecosystem
every ecosystem is dynamic meaning that
parts of the ecosystem both living and
non-living can and probably will change
over time
sometimes ecosystems might experience a
negative change like a disruption maybe
it's a particularly harsh and cold
spring and there aren't as many cones
and seeds for the nutcrackers to cash
changes like that can make it harder for
individual nutcrackers to survive and
raise chicks which can cause nutcracker
populations to get smaller
but on the other hand other types of
changes can help individuals in a
population for example if the ecosystem
experienced a particularly warm spring
after a wet winter there would be lots
of available food these types of changes
can cause more individuals to survive
have offspring and increase their
population
clark's nutcrackers and their
relationship to the hard to open cones
of the whitebark pine are just one
example of the kind of relationships
that drive many different ecosystems
just like how a decrease in nutcracker
populations could cause problems for the
whitebark pine and other species in the
ecosystem a change to one species and
any ecosystem can impact a whole web of
interconnected organisms
so next time you're outside and hear the
call of a bird think about all the
interactions that bird has with other
parts of its ecosystem these
relationships are all part of the
complicated web that is life on earth